quatrième budget et du ministre des
finances carlos tevez tao après avoir
annoncé des compressions au cours des
dernières années
on parle quand même d'une réduction de
la croissance des dépenses en santé et
en éducation 2 milliards 600 millions $
sur une année après avoir coupé court
aujourd'hui en décident de réel str et
de ramener la croissance des flottes des
dépenses en santé et en éducation à
4 082%
ça ne vient pas à compenser bien sûr
j réduction des dernières années pour
d'autre part que le gouvernement a
décidé de retourner qu'une partie de
l'argent de la taxe à payer envoi de 74
dollars à en faire avec 175 $ si vous
avez payé bien sûr une taxe à payer
en 2005 son combat pour remporter sa
troisième vertèbre gamins de 5 25$
donc sort par un peu de bien que cette
baisse d'impôts elles courent pieds des
contribuables mais samedi et pour
compenser bien sûr les réductions qui
ont été elle portante au cours des
dernières années par ailleurs
le réseau électrique métropolitain on
a beaucoup de précision dans le budget
qu'il était allons chez eux aujourd'hui
on prévoit pour le réseau électrique
métropolitain plus de deux milliards de
dollars de gouvernements de québec -
éjecté de l'argent a d'abord dans le
financement de base pas de tête
baissée d'également de laisser
c'est la plus belle foncière que le
gouvernement ou la caisse de dépôt de
balle captée on va laisser sommes tous
invités en fait le gouvernement qui va
au fond on pensé pour eux la gérance
métropolitain de transport et puis ya
de l'argent a également acquis les
droits du don qui veulent danser plus de
2 milliards de dollars que voir côté
il ya un problème aux contribuables
québécois au gouvernement du québec
ce qui est fondamental c'est pour mettre
l'argent en médiation c'est qu'on est
des skis en innovation et en formation
ont été également dans les
infrastructures le transport collectif
avec une politique de mobilité durable
et la terre étant en baisse le
gouvernement à peine ses objectifs avec
1 1% et celle des rois des 7000 surplus
encore cette année 2 milliards 500
millions de dollars en surplus et la
dette du québec qui est en place